obviously with guys like thug who have
been big supporters of you like when
thug pulls up do you just bless him what
thug gets everything when it first comes
out whether he like it or not
boom as soon as i make it he damn near
gets the samples some samples he get if
he wears i will not make it just because
it's just for him
that's fine like he would like i had a
lot of people wear it but a lot of
people aren't as influential as him i
can promise you that guy first hand has
helped me make majority of the money i
make today because it's not like okay
thug put it on i'm selling a lot of more
hoodies to all these people no once doug
put it on the people that i already know
is buying it faster yeah for sure i've
only got 10 people now they know thugs
on
that's my boy hey man i need that one
now they're buying it faster and now
that they're buying it faster people are
seeing them in it and when he put it on
it just turns it turns from just being a
t-shirt that i wear to support the homie
to drip but now people really trying to
like top him and it's not even just him
because it's like if you notice thug
don't be posting pictures of my [ __ ] he
don't have to right he really doesn't
have to because the people around him
that are so big that see him wearing it
i'll get a text from whoever like oh you
must have seen thug in it that's why
you're hitting me up right you know what
i mean once he started wearing it all of
these people that already knew me wanted
it more and faster and quicker